we are winning on the trans issue and so
any Republican who goes squishy not only
has zero backbone and maybe is missing
some other anatomical features as far as
I'm concerned but also just has no idea
what time it is does not does not have
any clear perception of where politics
is in this country
look at what's going on at Target
look at the Target CEO
had recently come out to defend the
pride month displays which include
bathing suits meant for tucking women's
bathing suits meant for men so that they
could tuck the features that are male so
they could look more like women even
though there are bathing suits already
that are fine for men to talk they're
called men's bathing suits
Target CEO defends the
lgbtq plus friendly displays for little
kids even
and he says that these products are not
only good for business they're the right
thing for society
the right thing for society
Target CEO Brian Cornell
okay
Target needs the Bud Light treatment
nobody expected that this Bud Light
boycott would be as successful as it is
Bud Light has lost more than 15 billion
dollars in market cap this has been
going on for so much longer than anybody
thought it would no one expected it
Target needs that too
sometimes it's very difficult to launch
a boycott
certain companies really have dominance
and it's hard to do it but but other
companies even when they have the
premier product in the category Bud
Light was the most popular beer in
America
other companies are susceptible to
boycotting Bud Light obviously was
Target obviously is there are other
options to Target there's Walmart there
is Costco I assume Jeremy's going to
have his own gigantic Superstore pretty
soon too come visit Jeremy's 20
000 foot retail shop
there are options it's too bad I like
Target well enough
I don't love it but they've got a decent
selection of Spindrift I'm a millennial
I like flavored Seltzer okay I'm gonna
have to give that up that's a sacrifice
that I'm going to have to make
in other Generations people have been
asked to make sacrifices like get on a
ship and go over to Normandy and be
strafed on the beach okay we're being
asked to make the sacrifice of hey maybe
drive a little bit further across town
hey maybe you're gonna have to pick up
your cup of coffee before you get into
the shop instead of in the shop like
target has the little coffee shops hey
maybe you're gonna have to trade out
your Target card for a Walmart card okay
Target is doubling down
on pushing kids into radical sexual
ideologies and transient people can't
let them get away with that
if
Target right now is is actually
following the Bud Light Playbook almost
to a t which is they're doubling down on
the radical sex ideology
and then they're kind of backing away a
little bit but then they're doubling
down again they need that BL treatment
baby right now go to carzing.com Knowles
buying a new car can be a stressful
experience for everyone especially if
you're a first time buyer or if you have
no credit before you walk into a
dealership and spend the whole day with
the crowds and the stress and the
potential that you won't even find the
right car you got to check out karzing
carsing is completely changing the way
that you buy a car online by partnering
with Credit Agencies lenders and over
twenty five thousand dealers Nationwide
karzing provides you with everything you
need before stepping foot into a
dealership you can instantly pre-qualify
online without affecting your credit
score get instant financing details
including what your down payment would
be your monthly payment term and APR
putting you several steps ahead of other
buyers once you find the right car at
your ideal budget all you have to do is
bring your saved deal voucher with you
to the dealership to finalize your next
ride super simple even if you're not in
the market for a new car check out cars
in anyway browse your dream cars see
what they have to offer for when you are
ready to buy
carzing helps make your experience
faster cheaper and less stressful go to
carzing.com Knowles today skip the
guesswork and find the best deals for
you carzing.com Knowles right now go to
puretalk.com Knowles remember the last
time you got a free phone how to start
started out great didn't it and then
came the Hefty activation fees the four
line requirements and of course that
binding contract Pure Talk is giving you
a free 5G Samsung Galaxy phone without
the feeling that you've been duped when
you switch to Pure talks unlimited talk
and text to data plan that comes with a
mobile hotspot you will get a 5G Samsung
Galaxy for free that's right unlimited
everything at a fraction of the price of
Verizon ATT or T-Mobile and here's
another thing you will be on America's
Most Dependable 5G Network how do I know
I'm a customer so make this switch to
Pure Talk the cell phone Wireless
company I'm proud to stand behind
because they offer great service and
they are proud to stand behind our
mission at the daily wire pure talks
us-based customer service team will help
you make the switch in as little as 10
minutes you can even keep your own phone
number it's just a great company great
service go to puretalk.com Knowles for
your free Samsung Galaxy when you sign
up for unlimited talk text and unlimited
data puretalk.com Knowles Pure Talk
Wireless for Americans by Americans
another company
has gone super duper gay not just Bud
Light not just Ford not just what was
the company what was the earlier company
today Target
even that very finest most cherished
brand of suburban white girls in the
mid-2000s North Face
has gone trans
hi it's me Patagonia a real-life
homosexual and today I'm here with the
North Face we are here to invite you to
come out
in nature with us wow this is nice we
like to call this little tour the summer
of Pride this tour has everything hiking
community art lesbians lesbians making
art last year we gave saw shade Across
the Nation and celebrated Pride Across
the Nation with hundreds of you across
the nation this year we're back back
again with two new stops Atlanta GA why
because you're there in Salt Lake City
we're coming for you
of course this year all these fabulous
speakers will be coming from inside this
TV to a nature near you so come outside
and celebrate the beautiful
lghgtv community
[Music]
that's pretty gay
so there's no way this is real is that
this can be real
the fact that I don't know I guess tells
you a lot about where our culture is
a very highly produced ad though
and the guy who's dressed up like a girl
he has a mustache I love that last line
there it gets to what we're talking
about with Jim Banks he says we got to
celebrate this beautiful this beautiful
community
and this is what animates so much of the
LGBT activism
is
a an inversion of beauty
that it's it's not really about a man
dressing up like a woman and it's not
really like a woman dressing up like a
man
it's about people who have every person
has some
Beauty to them because we're made in the
image and likeness of God it's about
people taking whatever beauty that they
have in them that they could cultivate
that they could accentuate that they
could simply allow to
exist
and trying to suppress that and to
distort that and to pervert that that's
what it's about
it's about highlighting the the
most grotesque images that that one
possibly can we've been talking about
porn a lot this week because I did that
interview with the uh porn expert and
this is one of the characteristics of
pornography is that it just becomes more
and more grotesque to the point that
something doesn't even appear like
pornography I had I was forced by my
producers to do a video of ASMR
which involved people like eating foods
and making disgusting sounds there's a
pornographic aspect to all that even
though it's it's so perverse that it
it's hard to even see how it in any way
could relate to sensuality but that's
what happens that's that's what happens
with grotesque rate and we're we're
living in a culture that is highlighting
the grotesque that cause a urinal on a
wall or on a floor a work of art
that calls the the most
intentionally
revolting things
beautiful and and does so in order to
force us to lie and to sever our our
relationship to sever the tether that we
have to reality into the truth to deny
that such an objective thing could exist
at all
I I've never owned a North Face I didn't
have enough money growing up in the
suburbs I was not a white girl I
remained not a white girl
tip of the iceberg
it's going to be so many Brands this
year we'll see if any of them hold back
now that they recognize that
conservatives are actually willing to
fight them on it to stop giving them
their money
pride month 2023 will be a very
important test of our political order
probably more so even than the 2024
presidential primary boy what a clip if
you want more of that if you want long
interviews if you want the yes or no
game if you want The Daily Show you got
to check out the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel and ring that Bell And subscribe
we'll see you next time